notre système démocratique local repose
sur l'engagement des élus parfois au
détriment de leur activité
professionnelle et souvent de la
création de droits retraite en effet les
élus qui perçoivent des indemnités de
fonction mensuelles inférieures à la
moitié du plafond de la sécurité sociale
1833 euros mensuels et qui n'ont pas
cessé toute activité professionnelle par
ailleurs ne cotise pas au régime de base
de la sécurité sociale il ne valide donc
pas nécessairement quatre trimestres par
an et leurs indemnités n'ouvrent aucun
droit à retraite au régime de base plus
de 80% des mers quasi exclusivement de
communes de moins de 4000 habitants sont
potentiellement concernés de surcroît
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
réduire leur activité professionnelle
pour exercer leur mandat pour leur
permettre d'ouvrir des droits à retraite
c'est amendement propose d'offrir la
possibilité à ces élus locaux d'être
assujettis aux cotisations de sécurité
sociale
donc la cotisation d'assurance
vieillesse sur l'indemnité de fonction
qu'il perçoivent cette disposition
s'exerce sur l'option de l'élu donc de
manière non obligatoire tout assurée
peut par ailleurs effectuer un versement
pour la retraite au titre des années
d'études supérieures et des années de
cotisation incomplètes ces rachats de
cotisations manquantes permettent de
conforter et de sécuriser la pension de
retraite des assurés ils sont limités à
12 trimestres or l'actuel dispositif de
rachat de trimestre est ouvert pour les
années incomplètes empêchant le rachat
de trimestres pour des années au cours
desquelles un élu n'en aurait validé
aucun c'est amendement propose également
d'ajouter les années de mandat électoral
à la liste des situations permettant le
rachat de trimestres je remercie
monsieur le ministre madame et Messieurs
les rapporteurs d'avoir été sensible à
cette cause que je défends depuis des
années cette réforme va rendre justice à
des milliers de maires de petites
communes merci monsieur le président
[Musique]